ragazzi miei questa settimana tre
episodi di folgaria pazzesca sta roba ma
oggi lo faccio perché questo è un
insieme di highlights
insomma della rai perché c'è stata
qualche giorno fa ho vinto due volte di
fila volevo renderla un video perché
viene live sono comunque la cosa
veramente [ __ ]
e importante quindi sono degli
highlights della rai mi potrete seguire
in live martedì giovedì e la domenica
per proprio sul canale ragazzi buona
visione della laga buongiorno vi ricordo
se volete supportarci a me all'agi anche
qua sotto trovate il tasto abbonati
potete abbonarvi sono i vari perche io
li farei wired big come prima mappa non
so se l'abbiamo mai fatta questa qua
ecco una mappa che ancora non è uscita
quindi vorrei farla meno male che è
uscito emma web quintegia va un grazie
mille
palermo nella sinistra uscita quella che
noi non sa come questo non lo fa da via
per cui ovviamente mi sono rotto oppure
che ora che la cosa su per cento ragazzi
se volete supportarci e di fianco e con
i super seeger se volete faccio una
domanda con l'associazione io vi
rispondo dotato decisione che città
occhio ma io non ho beccato quando
accidiosa i sì ci sono i circa questo
garantisco io non l'ho beccata degli
eserciti perché vi ripeto ragazzi su pc
ci sto giocando meno ultimamente sono
solo sulla playstation sulla playstation
non ho visto cit
per adesso quindi che dovremo giocare
anche a gta sulla playstation perché vi
fattibile giocare su pc ragazzi c'è
troppa gente che ero vino gioco come
doni che dici moda si fanno i cazzi loro
noi montre non vorrei farle agli altri
quindi va bene
stefano grazie video per laborazione
fratello grazie mille qualche video già
come danilo tech3 donation brother
grazie frate che somaggia
niente quindi problema è satto indici
però sa che non ne vedo quasi mai quadro
invitato io terzo spiga un secondo
perché lo fa il furbo
vabbè ex cram bordi gialli valgono 5
vogliono tanti giovanissimi potranno
tutti i gialli infatti prendono normale
lo metti siamo tutti un eros e allora
però qua va la difesa importante quindi
vai su buy in
nel 2009 si è tutti quelli che vanno
sull'alto sul nuovo giallo se lo
prendiamo per cui lo prendono presto
detto mannaggia il cacchio non ci arrivo
se andiamo su secondo sulle uova li
tieni grafici nemmeno uno che tieni
grappa ti carilo club ato così il nuovo
non lo può prendere e se lo prende lo
ritieni grava tosi di schizza via come
te che volete riusciamo però dalla lego
dopo che sono il momento l'ex uomo se
c'è un giallo ovviamente difendi il
giallo il contratto giallo nel giallo
come la tua vita siamo a 27 è
praticamente già dovremmo aver fatto
quindi difeso bene abbiamo attaccato
bene
ecco ci è riuscito con la ma dai che
culo avevano importante riuscirci da già
lab allora jam club e non ho mai perso
se perdo mi incazzo ecco quindi già clip
è uno di quelli che ti dico subito che
quando pensi di essere un pò sicuro poi
perdi non deve mai sarà staccato al
verde perché il verso e salti troppo
vicino al verde ci sta che ti colpisca
prima è capito quindi sempre prima
all'inizio la calzata devono rimanere
fuori 11 occhio resisti e occhio ai
quali si fa difficile registi
bene bravo finanza di sei nomi e non si
è successo alle volte ma può che
teoricamente ci farà fare col monte io
preferisco ex traguardo quello e unica
di cui ovviamente perché più merito non
ha la minima idea di cosa stefanati lo
saprai molto presto magari che voi avete
mitigazione hexagon oddio lloyd braun
io spero nel meglio allora prossimi fila
di tutti e due in che pazzesco davis
alta allora non sono più spiegato lo
devi saltare da un da una cella
all'analisi quindi hai capito quello che
fa circo de rimane sopra sopra perché
sotto tattiche o bada rom per cacchio
sotto no deve rimanere sopra sopra e
stare attento a cosa c'è sotto
importante perché se non guarito e sotto
pc nell'oblio occhio quando scendi santa
jive che aveva un personaggio di mare un
po in piedi che somiglia prende quel
perde queste cose ora stufa niente fa
niente stai tranquillo non cambia niente
i primi rom non cambia niente però sei
tranquillo
devi stare tranquillo non cambia nulla
si sa chi è il motivatore l'attivo è
perché sono mica cosa ci sta già versati
detto trainer base a queste ragazze che
noi dovevamo fanno fall guys a tempo
pieno in corso di folgaria ovviamente
sto scherzando la graziani tiberi che io
sono resistito molto di più ma sono di
nuovo la tua piattaforma all'inizio non
vuol dire niente
da qua inizia importare da qua da questa
più inizia a importare quindi tieniti
più soft che sopra possibile perché la
quale ha gentilizia cadere siamo i
quattro i treni in alto siamo i3p in
alto piano piano anche più piano
guardami guardami primi due mattino e
picchiato il personaggio porca vacca
sono rimanevo sul giallo quarto
[Musica]
sbagliarmi ma mia mamma mia si lui
perché è questo che deve avere le palle
ma perché chiamato arti i cazzi tuoi ma
conto tutta la strada super seno ed
adulta ma che poi mamma mia latti che
violenza ragazzi ragioni di tempo del
salso come ci si muove capito quindi va
bene allora basta ci sono 30 se ti vuoi
capire ciò che di solito in italia più
rosa di tutti vero da normale che vi
sono altri due super rosa comunque noi
abbiamo tre mogli intense sono questo
davanti il velino ok ok angolino in
testa anche essi si doveva allora hai
capito che si salta l'altro tasso il
quadrato non so se stai giocando l'ha
gestita player esatto che ci soffi così
è l'ultimo tasto poi non ci sono tanti
casi r2 che sai perché rappare all
agente o dipendenti poi ci sono i giochi
deve programmare nel caso te lo dico ma
che questo non la prese tutte in faccia
se la guarda se arrivato più alti di me
significa stare non mi risulta non deve
saltare non devo saltare mai nella vita
vada sarà eliminato sì ho vinto 9 la
dignità e ma ora che succede all'inizio
della normale stato guardo seminato che
tu no no io no io no ok che dovevo
capire che non si esalta lì ci siamo
riuniti tutti e tre la prima ragazzi
usciamo
siamo rimasti solo io come la nostra in
221 riguardo ragadi sentenza conclusiva
carico il varo qualcosa se vuoi guardare
malati ti spiego allora quasi posta il
santino vedi che fa lo spin ininfluente
rover e poi il vecchio relativa barca
trattati devi togliere ma chi cacchio è
da sempre la strada vivevano quando sono
passato alla mia che tristi lati mio
compagno a rebekah che capisce il mio
compagno subito democratica si 10 punto
stavo lì catena siccome la sinistra
sinistra cinesi
yes avrò se una stessa squadra cosa in
più la prima cosa è che allora qual è
arrivata dalla l'africa che vedo sempre
con ok allora la metà della squadra deve
essere da un lato dal 30 dall'altro
perché se siamo tutti nella stessa metà
abbiamo la metà dei cerchi e io provo
almeno per la metà di voi la metà
dell'affetto che dovreste meritare
quindi niente
adesso siamo in quattro qua e quanti
sono di là troppo pochi
vado io di là mannaggia da uno ce n'è di
la mannaia al cappio e questa squadra
ragazzi si può perdere perché in squadra
dipende quanto fanno schifo gli altri
volo è fatta di faccio commenti tanto
inutile ma fatevi entrare nel sito
internet cerchio anche quelli quelli
gialli fanno di più quanti siamo quanti
siamo da una parte dall'altra stai
facendo stati annoverati che lo stesso
pazienza
no porcos demonio parco maledetto con
l'andata quella mannaia ecco qua
che culo finale ma dove ma dove ma cosa
che ho è entrato io prima con tutta la
famiglia
ma cosa ma vai qui ho preso il caso mai
veramente ragazzi però se mi fate
entrare adesso taglio al giallo
no i lati come lo chiaramente raga
velocità guardarli e liscio di tuturano
ma magari domandiamo allora però tilton
gioco dove le registe casella adesso mi
butto a caso nella prima tanto siamo
all'inizio
guarda io ovviamente perché sempre cole
phelps c'è un conte che è vero ok a
farlo bisogna trovarlo ovvio che questo
è un gioco dove se viene eliminato dove
scusami se dovesse casi non viene
eliminato maresca le parole spronare
quando sono già tutti avanti come morire
perché quelli non devi stare avanti
perché se stai avanti viene buttato per
terra tipo leo poi li trovano la strada
tutti si butti con un pesce la stili
cioè stili e non arrivi primo ma
chissenefrega se non umori dello ster o
e aiutano che gli altri spingono in
tutti nuovi e tu sei significati non si
muove mai ad mai non hai capito come
funziona
ho capito appieno il tempo sembrava la
fia che ci ai supermercati durante la
quarantena tra l'altro è vera quella
l'hai vista prima da tatti vediamo se
faccio un film on the moon che adesso le
usciva sempre apple monte il resto solo
hexagone scenari scomodi meglio meglio
meglio come prima di hai capito cioè tu
devi saltare pian piano da una casella
all'altra ti sono già dato una skin che
molti imparano dopo un botto perché il
mondiali soccorrono e basta e correre
basta che non serve a nulla
dopo due finali è leo complimenti grazie
a perizia da gioca incredibile come fa
niente non fa niente perché i primi
le prime piattaforme non servono
veramente un cazzo fate a sapere se
l'ultima la penultima e dopo ce la
vediamo da vedere l'avvocati insomma
abbiamo trovato ok siamo tutti
nell'ultima però questa è veramente
questa è veramente infame non venire qua
intanto le palle non tenero ma prima
dobbiamo insieme quindi quel problema
questa grigia questa grigia insistito è
per leo un pochettino anche per me amato
c'era solo io ho vinto lo stesso voluto
che culo perché non so perché ero andato
to pin up your abbia molti pure dove
sarete fila ho visto durante la terapia
se dichiara perché mi sono buttato molto
più avanti ho fatto una cazzata totale
avevo molto più tempo fa ha voluto
veramente cool oraria me la meritavo lo
stesso però avuto culo perché mi sono
tuffato più in là di quello che dovevo
ed emulato papa ma d'oro qua ci ha avuto
un culo finale regala perché non dovevo
mai buttarmi lì fidatevi
dopo la vittoria di oggi per le j
[Musica]